hello happy new year happy 2020 did we
survive I hope so
it's me grace Helbig with another
episode of not too deep the first one of
this new year I have with me Elliott
Morgan you might know him from the
valley folk you might know him as a
comedian and his stand-up special holy
[ __ ] and what we did is we we took some
of your questions we gave you some
advice to help you enter 2020 with the
best of your thriving abilities from two
very non thriving low-key adults this
episode enjoy the first episode of 2029
- deep with Elliott Morgan we have
support today from Squarespace turn your
great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
where they're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything so you can
easily make a beautiful website yourself
and if you get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help you out so head to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the code grace to save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
[Music]
we're going Elliott Morgan thank you for
having me grace I didn't even welcome
you here but you're here it's wonderful
I'm happy to be here thanks for being
here the first episode of not too deep
2020 we're recording this on November
18th so there's plenty of time between
now and January 6th when this airs for
things to like [ __ ] hit things like you
know say fans yeah I think we'll be ok
yeah you talk about me and you we're
just in general I mean all of it
encompass can you imagine that that's
how I start this off but there is a
month and a half for you and I to break
up
yeah yeah but I think we'll be Fiat
there's plenty of time for but it's
gonna be the holidays it's gonna be well
we're becoming off of the holidays which
I've learned are your favorite things in
the universe you love a good Christmas I
do love a good Christmas has this always
been a disease that you've had um I like
I like magical fun things like Santa
okay and uh Mickey Mouse I mean I like
the Disney stuff too old were you when
you found out that Santa wasn't real I
actually don't remember the so it's
still theirs to check I don't know maybe
like I think I was a little it's I felt
too old I remember being like maybe 11
something like that but I'd already kind
of put it together and then my mom one
day was like ya know is it before that
she would always say well what do you
think and she thought that was a very
clever because she never wanted to lie
to her kids and felt weird about the
fact that it's a lie that's and your
mom's a psychologist right yeah so
that's a very and they go with that's
great and then that's how they
perpetuated the I I learned because my
mom was terrible at hiding gifts and
then I love to scavenger hunt and so
every year I was like cool can't wait
for Santa you hide the gifts in the bed
underneath of it and then up in the
closet yeah that's so easy you start
them in November and I every day peek in
while you're making your afternoon tea
and I did you have all wrapped gifts or
were some of the gifts unwrapped because
that's what Santa left her for you what
just that doesn't make any peasant ring
any bells no I would always have all the
wrap yeah now that I think about it it
was probably just a lazy thing but he he
it's like his it was like his presence
so they would always hide that one
really effectively but then all the
other stuff they would you like yeah of
course we got you presents but Santa
gets but no one cares about this right
now because it's January but I am
fascinated no my stepmom still writes to
Grace from Santa on all of the gifts it
is beautiful it's beautiful it's
beautiful when did you stop living
[Music]
I don't know like third grade and I
remember telling my friend in sixth
grade I remember being the one that
broke the news to my friend in sixth
grade with my other friend and both of
us going oh [ __ ] Lauren didn't know
she's do believe yeah
record player scratch before I had final
cut learned what a record player scratch
was did you say you were sorry or did
you say like well you're gonna find out
sometime anyway so he said this is real
life [ __ ] yeah that's what I said in
sixth grade I'm from New Jersey that's
how hard we were no I say I like prayed
to Jesus that I was forgiven I saw the
license plate on here that's an NJ Seoul
New Jersey soldiers he saw yeah it
sounds like maybe like their indoor
soccer team or something anyway first
episode of 20/20 New Year's has happened
Christmas has come and gone every other
holiday is come and gone other than
Easter and Valentine's Day Valentine's
you doubt them I went on Twitter and I
asked you guys for questions that are
advice driven that you might need help
on in the new year I know it's early as
we were recording this in the middle of
November but never too early to offer
some sound advice so should we just
there to ask then to people that still
believe in Santa I really doing their
best so let's just jump into these shall
we let's do it grace I'm excited and
nervous first of all do you have any
resolutions that's not a question that's
a personal question yeah I mean yeah I'm
sure you do it's always giving something
unhealthy up for a time do you like well
anything do you do resolutions like the
zetas is that a thing that you try to
abide by I don't do for fun I do but I
don't really care enough about I'll do
like a like a period of time for
something but then after that it's kinda
like whatever but no I don't really do I
don't really take it seriously okay in
my mind of it I'll do that better that's
not funny that's do you do you don't you
wouldn't you don't do this
I love new beginnings I love starting
over I think that's because I
continuously
do bad
and I love the opportunity to start over
so I love when the new year starts very
beautiful but it's like hey let's uh
let's refresh like my browser like my
computer when it freezes I feel like
that's me at the end of the year like I
just want to refresh everything it's
very happy time yes this is so stressful
and fun but yeah new year it's very
happy for like half a second and then
you realize that you're not gonna uphold
any of things that you really want to do
yeah all right so let's give advice to
people that that desperately need it
okay how to tell your family you don't
want to spend New Year's with them
something you've been doing since you
were zero years old I think this goes
and not just New Year's like how do you
tell your family that you don't want to
celebrate something with them as an
adult yeah
I guess you'd if it were me I'd be like
I'm gonna switch it up this year and I'm
gonna go do this instead mm-hmm and then
then their feelings are hurt I feel like
an edible arrangement solves all
problems or if you deliver if you
deliver what you assume is gonna be bad
news but you wrap it in like a literal
bow I think that they okay it's now a
Verret that as being like I can't
believe you wouldn't spend the holidays
yeah I can't believe you weren't
grateful for the edible arrangement I
did the chocolate dipped strawberries
doesn't add on a psychological like
double down on like now you can pivot
and say hey you're being ungrateful
yeah or you also recognize that your
parents brought you into this world and
know better than you and how dare you
want to go do something else for New
Year's I don't care how old you are it's
not worth the conflict it's not worth
getting involved in an argument to
assert yourself you should spend the
rest of your life with your parents
celebrating every holiday anyway with
them always one of the most attractive
things about an adult human is their
stunted growth yeah and I think there's
no clothes they could possibly be too
there what were we watching that had the
thing we're probably something on one of
them and it was the
there's a the reality show with the
person that was stunted and their growth
that's everything we were watching like
last night where they were waiting on oh
it was shark tank Oh shark tank and
where there was literally like living
with the parents of the parents had to
he like looked over before anyway if you
wanted to stay with them realistic yet
just hang out all the time just build up
that repressed anger towards your
parents and see what happened
should we established do I need to
clarify if I'm being sarcastic we talked
about how sometimes people don't know if
I'm being sarcastic or for me you just
did it is that good perfect how do I get
the next decade off to the right start
in 2020 what's something you will be
doing Hayley kind of like a resolution
question right yeah
2020 I don't realize the start of a new
decade hopefully might by the new year
my foot is peeled and I can use it again
and not limp I like to not limp into the
new year for those that don't know
Elliot's had a foot issue for a few
months um which is a fungus is it a
stress fracture a fungus and a stress
fracture are two very different things
you didn't see how the doctor kind of
winked at me when he saw yeah so you
couldn't see oh I spilled water sorry
those names the being injured as an
adult is an embarrassing thing I've
heard it would be and I didn't believe
it and then it happened and it is it
puts me in a bad mood sometimes cuz I'm
hobbling everywhere yeah it sucks so I'm
hoping I that's my big way of entering
the new decade is as a full-bodied
person and also I think maybe on top of
that not to you know add on to what your
opinion is that you appreciate your able
body oh yes I see yes that's a really
great idea it's an actual sincere real
thing that you have a sense of gratitude
for when your body is healthy because we
forget that it can break at any moment
all over the place yes yep that's great
that's mine too appreciate your body
the best way to fight a hangover or
diminish it or avoid it
I don't know even though you are going
to get completely wasted okay I don't
quite understand that Subin bosta wants
to know the best way to fight a hangover
or diminish it we're avoided I don't
know even though you are gonna get
completely wasted so that is inevitable
that you're gonna have a hangover so you
can't I mean you can fight it
you can't diminish or avoid it I think
the fight is hydration and you know all
the classic just greasy foods all of it
it's the three C's its carbs crapping
and what's the third one complete
cranial its carbs crap and is this a
real thing yeah that I used to tell
myself and apparently doesn't work and
then the other thing is those Blowfish
things Blowfish pills that actually
tablets yeah there's a series of fizzy
tablets that you can take before you
start drinking that supposedly help aid
the hangover after the after but you
take it the Blowfish once you take it in
the morning after mmm and they also make
you trip a little bit and see things
okay and remember the McDonald's trip
that I went on where I like was it was
right after this is like this is like
the beginning of 2019 mm-hmm I vaguely
vaguely remember that you took it too
and you also were but there's also like
liquid IV I've heard of from people on
Instagram that it's like every one
tablet in water is like the hydration of
like three glasses of water and even if
the placebo works go for it
but honestly it's just water it's
literally just water I think yeah maybe
that's what the water brand I'm starting
it's literally just water like the boxed
water yeah oh yeah oh wait that already
exists
[Music]
perfect marketing how do I find new
friends as a 26 year old guests are
thrown away the ones you got get rid of
start with your mom and dad the new
years with your new friends new friends
and when you're 26 that's like you
should that's a that's a hard thing well
you don't you don't know there's too
many you got to have stant yet it well
I've had this question a lot asked of me
in a bunch of different realms and I
think the thing to remember is that
everyone your age is also sort of
looking for friends like no one is
completely content and saying like this
is my group is done because everyone's
kind of moving through relationships in
different ways and so I think you kind
of have to like easier said than done
put yourself out there actually like if
you see someone or hang with someone or
talk to someone they're like this person
kind of gets me okay
I choose you let's maybe do something
else and see if we continue to get each
other in a way yeah
and that they're reaching out to you and
that you actually want to reach out to
them and it's like reciprocated and
stuff that's nice and it's not one-sided
yes a good time yeah also finding
hobbies as an adult I think there's also
a whole art form to realizing when you
don't want to be friends with somebody
anymore and it's not not a mean thing
it's not like a blow-up argument thing
we're like you sort of naturally drift
away and then you naturally drift toward
other people yeah I think you pay
attention to your own actions and then
glean things from that like if you find
yourself going to certain things or
looking up certain things online that
you find interesting and then you end up
exploring that and going in that
direction I think you could you can sort
of stumble toward a new social circle
yeah that makes sense yeah I did but
sarcastic thing and there's your trigger
warnings at the sarcasm it's not it's
not as deep as it seems okay last
question before we take a quick break
should I shave my back from random Mick
Rand
have you ever shaved your back shaving
your back shame your back I don't have a
hairy
I'll have that really
back ok humblebrag Harry but I've never
shaved my but there's still time there's
still time in 2019 I mean that might be
a resolution for 2020 I'm gonna shave my
butt I wish you luck shave my butt but
should someone shave their back I have
no opinion on that I couldn't have
I couldn't imagine answering that I
really have no idea if you want to I
guess how do you do it do you get a back
scratcher
oh I mean that's a shark tank innovation
a back scratcher that has a razor on it
so you don't have to get someone else to
help you shave your back that has to
exist already I mean that Lori can sell
that on QVC like that if they can so
that little thing that clips on to the
AC vent that holds the sauces saw some
yeah
we've been watching a lot of Shark Tank
you guys okay should you shave your back
if you can go for it but remember that
the maintenance is half the battle who
can I ask who asks a random makrand
silly Billy
okay his avatar is extraordinarily dark
I cannot tell its picture or hers or
their avatar but should you shave your
back I mean why not do it once try
everything try everything twice if you
haven't shaved your back at least once
you haven't lived oh now this reminds me
of something I need to add to my to-do
list okay we're gonna take a quick break
when we get back we have more answers to
your important 2020 New Year's questions
here on not too deep we'll be right back
[Music]
again support for today's show comes
from Squarespace they make it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
do you want to start a new business you
wanna showcase your work do you want to
publish content do you want to sell some
products or more they are the tool for
you they have beautiful templates
created by world-class designers and the
ability to customize just about anything
with a few clicks so you can easily make
a beautiful website by yourself they
also have powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics that help
you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box and there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever buying domains is
simple and you'll get the help you need
with Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support they empower millions
of people from designers lawyers artists
gamers even restaurants and gyms to turn
great ideas into something real so head
to squarespace.com slash Grace for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain that squarespace.com such
grace offer code grace we're back in
Elliott Morgan is here and we are
answering some of your most interesting
questions for the start of 2020 the
advice that you need to get your year
off on the right foot here's an actual
real question that I think is important
J once repeat the back shaving yeah
should the back be shaven J 101 to 102
find a therapist I've been dragging my
feet to start the process let's dive in
you and I both talked about this in
you've talked about this on the valley
folk I've talked about this in my own
videos I enjoy talking about it you
enjoy talking about I think yeah the
short answer is yes is it worth the
struggle to find a therapist yes I would
say so yeah it's also okay to what
therapists go and keep rolling through
till you find one that fits and one that
works that's the one thing that I didn't
actually fully register when I first
looking for therapists is that it was so
scary to me to even admit that I needed
a therapist so the first one that I went
to was a recommendation from a friend
and I was just like cool this is it I
don't even want to do this dance and
find another therapist it's too much for
me to even commit to this singular
person and the reality is it's worth
taking your time and actually like
speed-dating vetting the person that
makes sense and like actually works with
you in the certain way you start to find
out what you want from a therapist yeah
it's like finding a physical trainer not
that I know anything about that but if
you were to find a physical trainer and
expect to have like a built six-pack in
a week you probably won't but after a
while of doing it for like I haven't in
for like 2 ye may have three years yeah
and it's just like I'm assuming at some
point wouldn't get muscles but jury's
out but yeah it's it's a long it's taken
it took like two years before I was like
oh this is having like a substantial
effect on my life even though it wasn't
like going and being like I'm happy now
but how long did it take you to find the
therapist that you are have been
consistent with first one online
googling and then went oh so you did
your like research beforehand yeah and I
looked him up and looked up a bunch of
people and also would like find you know
other people's experience yeah it was
great and I've lucked out a lot yeah so
I think it's worth just starting to do
it I mean even if you do like what
Elliot did like the back end research of
like doing it online and not having to
like pay to do like a first session with
everyone every time that's good more
than most people do most people just
find the first person they go to them
and they say this is it this is what
therapy is and therapists are different
yeah yeah and some of them are not good
I really yeah I like talking about the
whole therapy thing a lot but I also
feel like a lot of people like the whole
I love learning about the new stuff that
I didn't know about myself that is bad
that I get to like quietly kind of try
to work on it's like finding the
be like ok I can be I can fly off I can
be an [ __ ] in this area so I'm gonna
try not to be and why am i why was I
being an [ __ ] and it's just fun to
like explore oh yeah once you have the
time under your belt of working with the
the same therapist then they can hold
you accountable because they know your
pattern to know your history they know
all of this yeah he just yells at me I
mean that's a dad I mean you know he
dances I live in Kansas City but I'm
thinking of moving back to my hometown
in Ohio can you talk me out of it is it
not from Mitchell Davis I was just
talking about him at the at the office
cool story
yeah it was what you know when you like
happy got when you love gossip about
somebody yeah yeah I live in Kansas City
I don't know I can't know where those
two places are I'm thinking of moving
back okay so I live in one place I'm
thinking moving back to my hometown can
you talk me out of it well wrong about
what's wrong with going back to the
hometown if they want to be talked out
of it it seems like they're giving up on
the place that they're in right now so
that feels like you need to discover
some things you like about the place
that you're in if you move it away from
your hometown that for some reason right
okay
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna give an honest
like opinion please I think that this
person is looking for some kind of
direction that they already kind of know
the direction so I think that the
question here's the question if the new
environment that they're living in the
Kansas City is beneficial to them on an
emotional level then staying there will
probably mean it's going to continue to
suck for a little bit and it might grow
more as a person whereas the home might
represent a safety in a comfort zone
yeah looking for reasons not to go back
to but the opposite could also be true
so who knows it could be that being away
is the comfort zone and dealing with
their problems they left behind at home
is the character building emotionally
like itself improving process so we
don't know
so Jonathan Troyer you're on your own
next best of luck to you okay it's
supposed to be really sincere advice I
feel like that was okay this is what not
too deep is a mix of complete dumb and
sometimes real sweet it's wonderful how
do you protect yourself from burning out
too quickly
I eat job school relationships etc who I
mean
you can't protect yourself from that
other than monitoring yourself on a
regular basis other than checking in and
going am I tired am i frustrated why
like constant in their inner
investigation I think and like honesty
with yourself and going cool I'm
frustrated with my job I'm burning out
on my job okay let me sit back and
reevaluate this if you can I mean
everyone's parameters are totally
different I think yeah and I think if
you end up like in a situation where you
things are going well but your and your
job is going well and you're getting
like accolades but you're still
exhausted and still not impressed by it
then it might be like a little bit of
that might be like a good sign that year
then you just go do mushrooms and
everything gets better mushrooms
mushrooms don't mushrooms - yeah best
advice for dealing with bad roommates
I haven't had roommates for Oh like 10
years maybe yeah I have never had a bad
roommate really no I mean I the last
roommate was an Irish philosopher so he
was he was delightful and he kept
everything way too clean well what you
really lucked out yeah I don't know I
mean I I would say you can I do like
house rules or house meetings that's
kind of cute they say Kaley says might
have been horrible this semester I can
barely stand to be home well if your gut
sucks if you're having roommates by
semester you know there's an end date to
this right like this is what you have to
deal with for right now and that you can
leave I think yeah if there are House
Rules in some way I don't know
form alliances yeah vote I mean create a
voting system for who gets voted out of
the apartment home alone them
create a big brother you know okay okay
there's a lot of illegalities that you
can explore my deteriorating body can't
handle spicy foods anymore but our
sneaky ways I can incorporate them back
into my diet a really great question for
2020 or the start of 2020 this is
important how do you sneak spicy back
into a body that is deteriorating first
of all I think you should see a doctor
that I don't want to give you any advice
that could cause more inflammation
though it it sounds like it's happening
are you I mean is the idea that you're
gonna fool your body into thinking that
the when I cake icing for breakfast I
fool my body that this is developing
news in it am I good this is like cream
cheese basically and cream cheese goes
on bagels and bagels are breakfast food
so this is breakfast food Wow yeah okay
I don't I mean you could put it in you
could chop up to the jalapenos put them
in a burger patty I think also yeah
that's true I think also it's by AC
foods your body can't handle spicy booze
anymore what about smokey you know
smokey is not spicy but it's still got
that I don't know watch the Food Network
I get chili like mild chili McMahon and
all that yeah cumin cumin which is worse
regret over something done or wondering
what if whoo Wow okay yeah um well I
don't know oh no I
I think the regret is definitely
something that you did that's bad I
think it this is from chicken broth dude
which is worse regret over something
done or wondering what if this is hard
so like forgiveness over permission kind
of deal oh yeah gonna do something bad
pens like what it is that you regret do
your gret like farting in the elevator
with someone on a first date or do you
regret asked like potentially not asking
that person out on the first date like
it
like if you're hurting someone with it
then it's probably better like if you
murder too much regret is gonna be more
than wondering what if you murders yes
it might be better to wonder what if
rather than actually murder but if it
comes down to yeah like asking somebody
out then also maybe not even a bad thing
because it allows you to feel you can go
through the fantasy of what it would
been like and that keeps you from
actually having to move back to Ohio I'm
getting a mixed up but there you go
chicken broth dude I hope some of that
helps you in some way that was that was
the big the big I want that one written
down on a quote yeah get it in your but
that's the best way to get through the
holidays alone well seeing as this has
come out in the beginning of January if
you went through the holidays alone
Congrats
you did it however you did it was the
perfect way to do it and we're all
collectively proud of you but I think
moving forward to get through the
holidays alone
I had holidays kind of alone last year
and the one cool thing I was in LA for
Thanksgiving and my friend Jocelyn and I
both weren't doing anything and she
invited me over to make these care
packages for women and homeless shelters
on Thanksgiving night and that's how we
kind of both spent Thanksgiving alone
and I was like this is so nice that's
very beautiful and also that's a really
good answer
volunteering is a very good things
that's like if you feel alone a lot of
other people do and so if you can help
why not help yeah I started doing that
that was my actually was my New Year's
resolution last year was to do the the
volunteering stuff and then to not to
try not to stop doing it well look at
you yeah I had a real thing you did
wasn't just trying to not drink for a
month which I did not do I mean at some
point maybe yeah we'll see yeah there's
still time it's 2020 okay we're gonna
take a break in one after this last
question
which is very light-hearted my doing
okay do you want you're doing great okay
how do you approach relationship
conflict my husband likes to avoid it
altogether but sometimes there are
things y'all just need to address how do
you approach relationship conflict if
someone wants to avoid it which is a
classic grace helbig move I'm just gonna
let you yeah I know I mean that I will
put this on your shoulders how do you
approach relationship conflict
relationship conflict which is basically
is it's [ __ ] conflict with someone that
avoids conflict at all costs I try to
bring it up as quickly as possible I
think like is quickly so it doesn't
Fester oh that's true yeah they usually
worried that you're gonna let it fester
and then if I don't hit it off at the
past it's gonna ya build and build well
that's I think important because people
that avoid conflict are usually not
avoiding it they're just letting their
brain fester in it for a long time yeah
and we I think you and I if I may speak
personally for a moment have you have
our trajectory of the quality of
conflict that we have has gone up a lot
like as a good from what it was a
hellish nightmare
oh yeah the trajectory has gotten better
I guess yeah like it's gotten low in our
ability to handle the quality of the
conflict yeah quality of conflict
compromising quantity is also gone down
all the numbers are good doc yeah it's
gotten better because we used we turned
it less into being you know a more
conversation based which is yes and
that's something I've learned is that
conflict doesn't have to be screaming
conflict can be conversational and that
deflates a lot of the intensity around
it that people that avoid conflict are
usually you know assuming it's going to
happen and it's like this Goodyear blimp
that's gonna be popped at any moment
when it turns out it could be um you
know like a
a deflated birthday balloon yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it should be thrown away yeah and
no one bats an eye at it okay we're
going to take one last break and when we
get back
guess what we have more advice Wow we're
20/20 we'll be right back with more not
too deep this week we have support from
Buffy Buffy makes bedding that is earth
friendly and cruelty-free their products
are made using only sustainable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are on your
bed and their latest product the breeze
is a comforter made from entirely 100%
eucalyptus fibers to regulate
temperature and keep you cool and
comfortable all night long it regulates
temperature which means there's no more
night sweats and as someone that does
occasionally suffer from the night
moisture this has been a fantastic
comforter I love it
so so much like I said it's made of
eucalyptus fabric inside and out it's
softer than cotton and naturally soothes
skin and is also hypoallergenic in fact
its high thread count shuts out dust
mold and mites for healthier sleeping
environments Buffy also offers a free
trial free trial try a comforter in your
own bed for free and if you don't love
it you can return it at no cost why not
choose 100% plant-based bedding that's
better for you and the earth for $20 off
your Buffy comforter $20 off visit Buffy
CO and enter code NTD that's Buffy CO
and code n TD for $20 off your Buffy
comforter guys have really really liked
this product this episode of not too
deep is supported by third love designed
with measurements from millions of women
third love's bra styles are made to fit
your life
they've over 80 bra sizes but know that
there's only one that matters
and it's yours and I can say from
experience these are the most
comfortable brawls ever and as someone
that prefers comfort over discomfort
like a weirdo I'm all about them
it turns down the most comfortable bra
that you'll own they have straps that
don't slip they have tag list labels
they have lightweight memory foam cups
that multi your shape
plus returns and exchanges are free and
easy and thanks to third loves perfect
fit promise every customer has 60 days
to wear it wash it and put it to the
test
and if you don't love it return it and
they'll wash it and donate it to a woman
in need they know that there is a
perfect bra for everyone and right now
you're getting 15% off your first order
go to third love , slash grace now to
find your perfect fitting bra and get
15% off your first purchase
that's third love comm such grace for
15% off today we're back with Elliott
Morgan and 2020 advice okay as always
doing great we're doing great this is
also a piece of advice that you should
tell yourself whenever you feel a little
stressed out just look in the mirror and
say we're doing great we that collective
we before we get into this last round of
questions submitted via Twitter of
course we have to check in on who would
you live or dead most wanna throw cold
spaghetti at currently I would throw a
babe spoiler alert do you say babe baby
baby Yoda from her from when we were
eight yeah yeah oh baby what I would
throw cold spaghetti at baby Yoda as a
snack not as anything aggressive and
that way maybe on the way he could maybe
stop at midair make it look cool or
whatever make it look like a Flying
Spaghetti Monster is kind of fun each
other did we do just good sense of humor
that's answer that's a great answer
how about you do you have to change you
have to do this every time I don't this
is my podcast
thank you I'm sorry thank you the other
question and I don't remember what your
answer was last time to tell us your
worst pants shooting story in three
words or three
small phrases mine college jogging front
lawn but I cannot remember last time you
were here here with Joe Bereta B Joe
Bereta D Chopra and I don't remember
exactly what your story was but whatever
comes to mind
worst pan shooting story in three words
there's three small phrases or a
combination church camp youth I mean I
just suppose it's young church camp okay
crying okay yeah that's a fun one oh
yeah I don't know if that's pants
[ __ ] or just you realize there's a
lot of things that could be a part of
that three word story yeah sees that
consonant fix the hang-up you know I
really didn't think I was gonna learn
much more about you on this podcast but
it turns out here we go always an
opportunity huh okay back into these
questions all caps from Clara I need to
get into shape girl how do I do that
with minimum effort but in a healthy way
and still drinking Red Bull that's a
little tiny you yeah I didn't realize
that I had a you know a secondary
Twitter account but this is all caps and
I think she's already drinking red ball
I need to get into shape how do I do
with minimum effort ooh that's gonna be
a problem because it's to get in shape
it takes kind of like a maximum effort
to do it and in a healthy way minimum
effort is usually a non healthy way to
get into shape so you got to kind of
reconcile those two thoughts I think and
realize if you want to do it in a
healthy way which you should do it in a
healthy way it's gonna be a little bit
more than minimum effort what would be
an unhealthy way yeah [ __ ] awful and
terrible or like unneeded operations
yeah yeah yeah you can also the you can
do it you can do it in a minimal amount
of time more so than like you can cram a
lot of effort into a small amount of
time that usually helps yeah I like
doing the thing
last like half an hour oh yeah I mean
there's and they still suck for that
half an hour I thought you meant like
the overall course of time of getting
into shape being minimal no the actual
like daily routine
there's tons of [ __ ] on YouTube on
everything that has like ten-minute like
at home workouts but yoga yoga is kind
of like yogurt and yoga those seem like
healthy things that the advertising
tells us I feel like that's like a good
you feel nice when you're done mm-hmm oh
yeah yeah I guess have you done hot yoga
I'm sure you know I will have a full
pant I have a panic attack thinking
about the idea of doing hot yoga I'm
sorry brother it's too hot it's an yoga
and yoga yoga in general gives me
anxiety because just it's a room of
people on the verge of farting and I
hate like my empathy levels go to the
tenth degree of like feeling for
everyone that's trying to hold in a fart
the whole time in a public situation we
just did the to date this podcast a
little bit we did the 5k that you're at
the Jurassic Park I believe I did the
Jurassic Park 5k Universal well I got to
witness every person go by the finish
line but yet there was a it was one of
those moments were mornings where I was
having a hard time with my stomach oh
and I realized that I was outside and I
just stopped caring about halfway in the
breeze breeze and I was like this is a
perfect opportunity for me just to not
trying to be rude but just so if they
had hot yoga outdoor Universal during
Jurassic Park Paint Bucket yeah yeah
anyway so yoga is the short answer for
all of this graduating soon how do you
deal with the emotions of the ongoing
question / anxiety of what's next well
dang okay how do you deal with the
emotions of the ongoing question /
anxiety of what's next ooh I mean I
think you can reframe the fact that
anxiety isn't a fear of what's next but
more an excitement for what's what's
next that you're nervous about all of
the possibilities
that's beautiful that's beautiful that's
perfect and also what's next you don't
have to know yeah you can just start to
figure out I don't think it's like a
black and white answer of like here's
exactly what's next unless you're like
going to med school or something like
that but otherwise it's like I'm going
to start to figure out what's next when
you don't when you have in a big empty
vacuum it means that anything can pop
and when it does it can be the most
explosive wonderful thing ever you just
have to hold the vacuum of not knowing
and walk around with it until something
pops that sounds like I'm high yeah that
sounds great on that same no how do I
find motivation in a job that I hate but
it monetarily obligated to keep I think
that's tough very tough I think you
start to find small moments of silly fun
I'm talking non-harmful office pranks
yeah like whoopee cushions you can't get
fired for that that makes everyone's day
better I don't know what you do for a
living just like I'm a surgeon no one
sits down and if they hear that kind of
gastrointestinal noise everyone's great
that's a great idea just make it fun for
yourself make little games and yeah like
put put something in the water cooler
woody what happens when you feel trapped
like that and you're like having to do
it because you got to have the the money
and it sucks the whole time that's like
that just will I think there's also a
bit of like maybe start exploring some
start trying to commit to doing little
steps to help you get out of that
current job that way even if it doesn't
work or even if it's not an opportunity
at that moment you still feel a little
bit of sense of reprieve I wouldn't do
it on the clock but do it when you get
home and Google a little bit and try to
I mean if you're out of this job already
you can but also if this job is if you
want to find motivation in this job
doesn't sound like there is motivation
there other than there's money coming in
through it I think you can find fun in
the job whatever
and then find motivation to look for
another job that like you said has more
inspiring after-effects to it when you
moved out of your hometown to somewhere
new how long did it take to adjust hmm a
while
I think la took like I don't even think
I'm fully adjusted really yeah I know
places to go I know people here but I
think you're always gonna have to kind
of move with and evolve with whatever
yeah wherever you live I would say yeah
it took like a year and a half two years
for me to feel not scared to drive on
the freeways here oh really
and you can't Florida where you had a
car yeah I just thought but it's so flat
and Florida and then here the hills and
everything just freaked me out
like I couldn't I couldn't believe I was
like it my car's gonna fall off and so
that was scary and then learning where
everything was is terrifying because
it's a huge city and then I thought I
was gonna you know get killed at some
point but yeah I would say a year and a
half two years okay but you're still not
you I mean I think like just in terms of
like knowing where you are and feeling
like relatively comfortable going places
and that sort of thing yeah I would say
like a year or two depending on like if
you move knowing people already and you
move kind of like knowing the place
already or if you're moving like blind
to a brand new place if you're living
alone if you're moving out of your
parents place and you're living alone
for the first time I feel like that's
sort of the most exciting times ever
mm-hmm it's very loool to figure out it
yeah it's like you're pretending to be
an adult but at the same time you like
kind of are one pretty neat you kind of
are one and you're like you know faking
it in life to everyone else you're kind
of like pulling the wool over their eyes
it's okay I'm an adult but I'm not
does his experience as costume
characters affect his views on 2020 just
giving him a chance to plug holy [ __ ]
that's very sweet
my views out toward a cooler ya know
it's it does yet though it a costume
characters affect my views on 2020
that's very sweet having a special out
called holy [ __ ] that's available I mean
forms and by the time this comes out it
might be available on a real big one but
I don't know what yet and so we'll see
it's called this I don't know where it
is I don't know how much it would cost
and I don't know if it's available in
Canada
keep refreshing that Google search for a
home but does your experience as costume
characters affect your views on 2020 I
miss being goofy so much really I think
it was so fun it was such a cool thing
to do when I was a teen I wouldn't wanna
go back and do it but it's real sweet
how long did you do that for like two
years I was doing the mat it was right
when Katrina hit okay like that was
bright in the middle of it that a night
because I remember being there and being
like what's going on huh oh cool and
then like having to go yeah it was a
very very fun they took us to the
make-a-wish Foundation one time where
they loaded us up in a van and then they
brought us over to the center and it was
the sweetest thing in the world because
it was a bunch of like just normal
people and then you put on the cost and
these kids just like lost their minds it
was real sweet and then they gave us
like really nice breakfasts and we're
just very thankful we got assigned it
yeah that was exactly you know like a TV
it's some of the kids but I'm not gonna
you know there was one it was about yay
high and it no but it was very
appreciated the joy I brought to these
children but I love the pancake yeah it
was really good
do you have a good recipe for soup no
but you've been making some great matzo
ball soup really big fan big fan - I
have a great recipe absolutely not so
there's that on that that turkey chili I
made was pretty good but that isn't
really count yeah what's the soup and
what I mean we talked about this with
Joe Bereta how can I make sure I have
the best time in Vegas next year all
right
here we go he's sleeping on this one
finally here comes Elliot's expertise
all right you're gonna want to go to old
Vegas you're gonna want to book your
hotel well in advance you're not
watching this podcast he is fully
gripped down in the chair as if an
earthquake the hotels are super cheap if
it's during the week it's like 30 or 40
bucks a night or something
if you can go in the old ones and get a
suite there it's just silly fun and yeah
it's dirty and gross but that's part of
the charm don't expect to have a lot of
fun don't expect it there to be a lot to
do
make sure your standards are as low as
possible because you're walking into one
of the filthiest places in the world and
then accept it for all it is have a
great time with your friends walk around
drink outside feel cool gamble a little
bit don't gamble too much and do the red
snake on real etiquette chains and
there's also before it gets completely
wiped out of Vegas in what is it the
plaza I'm gonna plug this because my
favorite game of all time it's tiny
plastic ponies that you bet on them as
they run around this racetrack and it's
like watching toys it's like imagine Toy
Story 4 but you could bet on who went
there we went to the downtown area
specifically just to play that game
because it's like the only one left in
it was I mean I didn't want to see that
Lady Gaga show I didn't want to see
Criss Angel I wanted to see the tiny
plastic ponies at the Plaza Hotel and
guess what no one was there and they
were perfect and then you immediately
won like 300 bucks yeah then I lost it
big time I'm very good at that game what
are things that were new for you in 2019
that you want to keep doing in 2020
that's it I feel like there's been a lot
of new stuff this year and traveling has
been really nice yeah do that more we
won't repeat yeah a lot of it we will I
think that's excited about that I think
that's healthy and good and wonderful
for everyone
I do recommend volunteering people
should try that that's another one keep
doing that stuff what about you what a
day do you in 2019 that I want to keep
doing in 2020 cooking you've been doing
a lot of cooking actually like making
food and also like making matter I
learned how to grill yeah it turns out
is the easiest goddamn thing in the
world I know that's the whole thing it's
it just looks like one giant explosive
device to me even though that's what a
stove looks like to but this looks way
more
like outside things could happen and
turns out it's pretty okay even though
it's just one you could see the propane
tank so it's like watching potential
disaster and yeah I think I'd like to
grow more in 2020 you you've been doing
great work Thanks the grill sing up
sausages and putting it into the ground
turkey was a bold move it didn't work
out you know what you gotta you gotta
try and fail to learn to succeed okay
last question oh okay I'm starting an
internship abroad in the new year tips
on how to make a good impression on my
first day I think this is kind of a
broad question how do you make a good
impression on your first day in a
professional environment here's my
answer
okay I think you stay in your car you
get you show up early change your career
you go home cry you stay in your car for
a second you breathe for a moment
through your nose you remember no one in
there doesn't want to like you everyone
wants to like you so you got that going
for you yeah when you go in and you say
hi to people you make eye contact and
you keep focusing on the fact that
you're you you're fine everyone's in
there to have a good time don't make too
much eye contact no don't be a creeper
yeah it's gotten me in trouble before
and it's bad yep that's gonna be the
learning curve is finding the right
amount of eye contact but also that's a
great point that no one wants to hate
you like I yeah it's an easy concept but
I don't think it gets sent out loud and
it's actually kind of very empowering to
hear that out loud to be like yeah every
job that I've ever worked at and if
someone came in and was new I've never
thought can't wait to [ __ ] hate this
person every single thing they represent
this person better rule them better fix
my problems oh I'm gonna be their
problem yeah that's a stand up that's
what I do tell myself were stayin up
shows before I grew up I go okay they
probably just they probably don't
already hate me and probably don't want
to hate me so much Oh No
and of course that would yeah yeah yeah
I mean that's how we all operate just
keep spilling water every time I'm
you're making a great impression yeah I
think you go in and you also realize
that like impressions aren't totally
made on the first day especially if
you're going into a new job like you're
gonna be there so this one day doesn't
fully define your entire existence in
this work environment yeah so all you
have to do is go and do your best and
then slowly over time become more
comfortable with everyone and everything
you're doing yeah you can start acting
like you've been there for like a while
now you just walk and you pleasantly say
hi to people and then if you imagine
that it's like a day in the middle of
your experience or your employment that
maybe that I don't know pants were shot
pants the boss yeah what's the worst
that's gonna happen you get fired you'd
never have to make an impression at that
job ever again yeah and then everyone
gets to live with the legend that was
this person that came in
pants their boss day one and left
Elliott thank you for being here thank
you guys I hope it wasn't okay this was
wonderful for having me very nice start
to 2020 here are not too deep Happy New
Year happy holidays to everyone
yeah I'm still strange that we're
recording this in November 18 but still
happy 2020 if the world hasn't
completely exploded then this podcast
will be up and live for you guys to
listen to Elliott where can people find
you working they find the special we're
gonna find belly folk you can find holy
[ __ ] on Amazon Prime video and you can
find me at Instagram calm slash Elliott
Morgan two hours two teas and also at
youtube.com slash the valley folk and
patreon.com slash the valley folk which
is a little group that we do that does
comedy hey thank you alright well see
you guys next time on an episode of not
too deep happy 2020 goodbye 2deep 2deep
2deep 2deep beck not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer Melissa D months camera
operator Katrina Henning edited by
Shireen Lonnie Eunice post-production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music
[Music]